All right, let's hear the latest from Fox
news at senior judicial analyst Andrew epal
Caetano,
who very clearly believes that onald Trump
has committed crimes in this entire kraine
fiasco.
That onald Trump has committed impeachable
offenses in this entire thing.
And Andrew epal [inaudible] went on with Shep
Smith and he talked about what Trump has done
in the context of the kraine phone call and
the Biden family a smear investigation.
And let's take a look at this, and this is
making the Fox news audience go absolutely
cuckoo for cocoa puffs.
The president admits that on a phone call
with the president of kraine, he requested
that the president of kraine investigate his
wenty twenty political rival, Joe Biden.
Is that a crime?
It is a crime for the president to solicit
aid for his campaign from a foreign government.
So that would be it.
With that too, which the president has admitted
is in and of itself a crime.
Yes.
This is the same crime for which the Trump
organization was investigated by Bob Mueller
who couldn't, who decided not to seek an indictment
because there wasn't enough evidence?
Well, no, he said he didn't seek an indictment
because he wasn't charged because of the DOJ
rule.
That said, you can lay it out but you can't
charge.
That's on the obstruction of justice on whether
or not there was a conspiracy.
We during the Russians and the Trump campaign,
he said there's some evidence but not enough
to indict.
It's the same crime and agreement or a solicitation
for assistance for an American campaign regulated
by the federal election commission where you
are seeking the assistance from a foreign
government.
That's the crime
and then the question of is this impeachable
a little bit later in the interview and remember
this is Fox news folks
based on the specifics of what we know, forget
about the phone call, forget, forget all of
the things about which we have no knowledge
just based on the things that the president
has admitted.
The president's admitted that he made a phone
call to the new president of kraine.
The president has admitted that he had discussions
about investigating his upcoming wenty twenty
primary, wenty twenty presidential rival.
Based on that in and of itself, how serious
is this matter for the nation and the democracy
legally speaking?
When Bob Mueller made his findings that the
obstruction of justice is a, it could be an
impeachable offense that's equivocal.
Bribery absolutely is an impeachable offense.
There's no equivocation.
Why do I say that?
Because it's stated in the constitution the
basis for impeachment treason, bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors, so
understand that the important part about this
is not, Oh, Fox news is no longer going to
be a right wing propaganda outlet.
They still are going to be a right wing propaganda
outlet.
The upside of all of this is that the behavior
of this particular Republican president is
so outrageous that it is starting to make
Republicans eat themselves.
There are some right-wingers that are starting
to turn on each other because what onald Trump
is doing is indefensible.
You have some Republicans like Mitt Romney,
Justin Amash, who I guess is not really a
Republican anymore, but he was, he no longer
is because of onald Trump, I guess, at least
partially who just can't keep pretending that
everything is fine and it's generating some
division within the party and it's a great
thing for the left if we can take advantage
of it.
There are some rats so to speak, who are jumping
ship.
There are other rats who in the scramble are
just starting to eat other rats.
And in the end, it's crazy that this is the
fundamental question of the time between now
and the November of wenty twenty election.
What will determine the wenty twenty election
is do Democrats eat themselves more or less
than Republicans?
For example, arguing about, as I told you
yesterday or earlier in the program, rather,
uh, about the scope of what the Trump impeachment
inquiry should be.
Uh, you are going to see some Republicans
start to pretend they never even really supported
onald Trump to begin with.
You are going to see other Republicans double
down.
It will cause chaos hopefully for their wenty,
wenty reelection campaigns.
Who's with who on this?
And the left needs to, instead of doing the
same thing, the left needs to take advantage
of this opportunity.
Take advantage over the internal disagreements
that the Rite is going to start having.
Uh, and don't do the same thing.
Don't start arguing about whether to have
an impeachment inquiry.
There is an impeachment inquiry.
That's it.
Don't start arguing over issues that ultimately
it they would be Pyrrhic victories to come
ahead on you.
There are arguments Democrats can choose to
have where some faction can win the argument,
but do so much damage in having the argument
that we end up just helping onald Trump get
himself reelected in November of wenty twenty
which still may happen now as far as Fox news,
judge Andrew epal Caetano here.
What he's doing here is not controversial,
okay?
What Andrew epal [inaudible] is doing here
is he's ignoring whether someone has an R
or a D after their name and he is doing what
judges are supposed to do.
He's looking at the text of statutes, the
text of what makes a president impeachable
and then he is applying the law to the actions
that onald Trump has taken, at least the ones
that we know about that haven't been covered
up.
And then he spits out an analysis that is
merely a calculation of these are crimes,
these are Trump's actions that makes Trump's
actions, crimes, that makes Trump's actions
impeachable actions.
And that's it.
And the fact that this is so notable that
this is happening.
Um, it tells us about the sad state of partisanship
that we are experiencing right now.